will the Republican party is finally
behaving rationally Republicans are
panicking that the now multiple arrests
of failed former president twice
impeached twice indicted Donald Trump
may actually Boomerang on them and be
damaging big picture there's an
interesting article in the hill by
Alexander Bolton called Republicans fear
Trump legal woes will Boomerang on them
Senate Republicans are worried that
Trump's legal troubles will create a
major headwind for Republican candidates
in 2024 they say the battle between the
justice department and Trump who pleaded
not guilty Tuesday just as his
unsubstantiated claims that the 2020
election was stolen became a Prominent
Point of debate in last year's primaries
they worry Trump's dominance of the
media Spotlight will turn off swing
voters especially Suburban women and
hurt their chances of taking back the
senate or protecting their small house
majority the article goes on to include
a number of quotes from different
Republicans this is a logical reaction
to what is going on now there is a group
of people that is choosing to narrowly
focus only on the presidential race and
we will look at the polling in the
presidential race a little bit later
today
you could convince yourself and maybe
others if you look only at the
presidential race that it is quite
binary and it doesn't have any
trickle-down effect what is happening
with Donald Trump let me tell you what I
mean by that you could look at the Trump
arrests and look at the Republican
primary and say to yourself listen
if Trump's arrests hurt Trump someone
else will win the primary and then that
person will face Joe Biden and they
might win or they might lose and it will
have nothing to do with what is going on
with Trump in other words the context is
Trump's legal troubles will only affect
who is the Republican nominee and beyond
that it will not have any broader impact
on the Republican party there are two
problems with that relatively narrow
Focus problem number one is that indeed
if Trump is leading the Republican
primary for several more months but then
he's arrested a third time and
potentially arrested a fourth time and
then it becomes clear he can't really
campaign because he's just going from
Courthouse to courthouse and Ron
DeSantis or someone else ends up winning
the primary the impact of that last
minute Collapse by Donald Trump doesn't
end with the Republican primary and
there is the belief and I believe it is
a war warranted belief that if such a
shake-up were to take place it would
weaken whoever is the eventual
Republican nominee against Joe Biden so
that's one way in which thinking of the
Trump arrests only is relevant
to the Republican primary is wrong but
what Republicans are increasingly
concerned about now is very serious
which is that this entire circus
atmosphere and Sideshow nature of what
is going on which also by the way
includes some Republican candidates
saying I would pardon Trump and others
saying I wouldn't and this just becoming
the circus that it is it may just be
very bad for random Republican Senators
seeking re-election for random members
of the House of Representatives some who
are supporters of trump and some who are
not that it will create a broader
problem for any Republican that is
running in November of 24 including
simply that the Trump Fiasco might
reduce turnout and make some voters stay
home who would otherwise vote to
re-elect some of these Republicans it's
too early to know whether that fear is
backed by data but intuitively it makes
a ton of sense we'll leave that question
there and now I want to look at a little
bit at some new National polling we do
have a new poll in which Joe Biden is
leading Donald Trump by four points this
is a hypothetical 2024 general election
poll this is a poll that assumes trumps
the Republican nominee Biden is the
Democratic nominee and the election were
held today
in this poll Quinnipiac Biden leads
Trump 48 to 44. Trump's support has
dropped two points since uh Trump was
um since the last time this poll was
done in late may I like to get a more
General look at polling if we look at
the best rated polls b-plus and higher
we have a recent you gov poll that poll
says Biden and Trump are actually tied
among registered voters with Trump
leading by one among all adults we then
have the a minus rated Quinnipiac poll
the one I just described to you it has
Biden ahead of Trump by four and then we
have an A minus Suffolk University poll
which has Biden leading DeSantis by
seven and Biden leading Trump by two
what we can say at this point is that
there is a really big red flag and the
red flag isn't oh Biden's winning or
Biden's losing or whatever the red flag
is Biden has done a number of good
things as far as presidents are
concerned we have a stable economy at
worst if not a solid economy
Trump has been arrested multiple times
lies constantly
fundraises on grifts is facing all sorts
of different problems after losing for
the Republican party in 2018 2020 and
and pushing them to lose uh or not win
by as much as they should have in 2022
and given all of that Biden's only
winning by one two three or four
that's the red flag this if this country
made sense
if voters reacted sensibly and soberly
and thoughtfully to the facts of the
world Joe Biden would be leading at
minimum by double digits and so to
anybody who's looking at this current
election and saying oh this is they're
just these Republicans aren't going to
win there's no way Trump can win there's
no way this country would re-elect Trump
the polling even if you believe right
like the best one of these polls the
strongest one of these polls is Biden
leading Trump by four even if you
believe that
it is an absolute and total horror show
and we should all be very much aware
that Trump could win
and we need to activate any tool we have
to prevent that from happening and of
course by the way I mean an illegal tool
including voter turnout campaigning
debate prep surrogates what all of the
legal things all of the legal things as
always as if I even really have to
clarify that scary stuff
on tape showing National secrets to
guests at his Resort
and uh the best poll we can find has him
down four just absolutely horrifying
stuff I'm not going to spend a ton of
time on this but because I told you
about it earlier this week I do want to
follow up earlier this week after being
arrested for a second time Donald Trump
went to the Cuban restaurant in Miami
Versailles and at that restaurant Donald
Trump promised food for everyone okay
remember this bizarre moment are you
ready are you ready
food for everyone
[Applause]
okay my immediate reaction was I'd get a
credit card up front before giving
anybody food that supposedly Trump is
going to pay for the Miami New Times can
now report that Donald Trump did not pay
for anybody's food at Versailles the
article confirms Trump opted to
decompress with a trip to Versailles in
Little Havana
Trump and his Entourage arrived there
shortly after leaving the courthouse
Trump said food for everyone so the new
times wondered did Trump treat his fan
club to some food
it turns out no one got anything not
even a cafecito to go
a knowledgeable Source assures the new
times that Trump's stop was 10 minutes
long it didn't leave time for anyone to
eat anything much less place an order
and of course Donald Trump did not leave
any instructions to Bill him or charge
his credit card or whatever the case may
be this is a very small story in the
broader context of everything that
happened in the last week which was an
absolutely insane week it is not the
most important story but it is a
reminder that this is a habitually
dishonest and Despicable guy who cares
about his supporters only as far as they
are useful to him and the Versailles
incident is the epitome of that he shows
up they're cheering they sing him happy
birthday they're praying over him the
photo op is extraordinarily useful and
so he yells out food for everyone
but then he leaves because he doesn't
actually care about it he doesn't
actually want to give anyone anything he
doesn't actually respect or value these
people anywhere beyond the extent to
which they are useful to his campaign we
saw it with the fundraising grifts we
saw it around elections we've seen it so
many times food for everyone I would
have gotten the credit card up front he
paid for nobody's food we have a
fantastic program for you today few
programming notes number one we will be
off on Monday for Juneteenth number two
then I will be here Tuesday but then
away for a wedding not my wedding I will
be on the west coast for a wedding so
after the Tuesday show for which I will
be here then we'll have some great guest
hosts I think you will enjoy it make
sure that you are subscribed to the
YouTube channel we made more progress in
this last week towards the 2 million uh
subscriber goal than we have in many
many many months let's close out the
week super strong at youtube.com the
davidpackman show it's free it costs
nothing and also we are starting to put
a Republican primary debates on the
streaming calendar I know that it is
insane because it is only June we're
getting to the end of June into July of
2023 but the Republican debates are
starting the first one is scheduled for
August 23. uh it will be a Fox News
debate we are figuring out whether we
can stream it live without getting
absolutely crushed by Fox news's
copyright enforcement division
I will have news about that soon but we
will do everything we can to bring you
as much of campaign 2024 as we can let's
take a very quick break we've got a
packed program ahead of the three-day
weekend
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David packman show continues to very
proudly and humbly be primarily
supported by viewers and listeners who
sign up for memberships on our website
we had some incredible new levels of
support earlier this week with
everything that went on the Trump arrest
and all of it and I just want to
encourage you keep signing up at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
single day for our members called the
bonus show where we make money on the
bonus show as Alex Jones likes to say
you can use the coupon code indicted
again
indicted again that's the code no space
lowercase Capital doesn't matter as long
as it's all one word at joinpakman.com
let's now speak to some of those very
folks in our audience we do this on the
Friday show we do it via Discord you can
find the Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord that is the place to do it we
are going to start today with John from
Connecticut John from Connecticut
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey can you hear me yes
cool so
um my question is more along the lines
of
why this seem like so many people
nowadays especially on the right seem to
have a problem with any critical
thinking like it's so hard for people to
understand to like you know look at a
situation that they're not used to
understanding and they can't like they
just immediately jump to conclusions two
answers to that number one there are
some people
who just have not been taught how to
think critically and so they don't right
and in a sense you can't blame them to a
degree because if you haven't been
taught something how can you be expected
to know how to do it on the other hand
there are those on the right who
recognize that when people really apply
basic critical thinking and media
literacy techniques to right-wing
ideology it very quickly falls apart and
this is why those who are wise to this
actually don't want critical thinking
taught in schools they realize if too
many people start thinking critically
it's bad for the Republican party so
it's a combination of ignorance and bad
faith actors and in some cases maybe a
combination of the two
what do you think is more prevalent bad
faith actors or people who are just
ignorant I think among vote the average
voter I think it's ignorance and listen
the left is not exempt from this by any
means there's a lack of critical
thinking on left and right and we could
slice and dice it but I think that the
vast majority of those who aren't
thinking critically aren't thinking
critically because of ignorance not
because they are bad faith actors
they've been sort of indoctrinated
as a result of not thinking for
themselves in a critical way and it's
really an indictment on the educational
system and the media system as well
right
um so the last thing then is what do you
think would be the best way to like talk
to the people who are more ignorant that
are kind of easier to you know maybe
give them some evidence to hopefully
change their mind on that type of
situation the best path for the folks
you're talking about is actually not to
give them evidence it's to know how to
use a gentle empathetic Socratic method
of questioning to get them to say hey
maybe I'm not actually that solid in
what I believe so it's where did you
learn that oh how do you know that's
trustworthy in general how do you know
what things are trustworthy what's a
good way of figuring out what to believe
that approach rather than beating people
over the head with evidence is probably
going to be more effective
all right thank you very much David all
right John from Connecticut great to
hear from you why don't we go next to
Nicole from Utah Nicole Welcome to the
program
thank you so much David I my question
this time is actually going to be
related to what Trump has said in
relation to the Ukraine war do you think
he has any chance if he does get elected
which is a long shot anyways does he
have any amount of chance at stopping
this war
but he claims listen he will he says
let's go through it in Parts Trump says
he will end the Russian invasion of
Ukraine in 24 hours
when he's asked how he says oh I'll talk
to them pretty silly pretty dumb the
only way that I see that conflict is
ending quickly
would be if basically Ukraine gives up
and Russia just takes over so even in
the best scenario it's not going to end
in 24 hours now does Trump have a chance
at actually ending it I think he does
have a chance in the sense that every
every president has a chance the the
question is the the detail of how you
would actually do it but sure I mean
Trump has a chance he just doesn't have
a great track record that makes me think
it's it's highly likely
mm-hmm
that's all I have for you today David
all right thank you Nicole Nicole from
Utah great to hear from you uh once
again let's go to Roberto from Paris
Roberto from Paris welcome to the David
packman show
what's on your mind today
Roberto from Paris please
Roberto last chance you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes I can
oh perfect oh my gosh I can't believe
I'm on I actually have a membership even
though I used to live in France and I
love it I love being able to see the
show commercial free well thank you so
much
do you think that all a lot of
candidates have joined
on the Republican side to split the boat
since the primary I may be wrong but
isn't it not like a winner takes all so
that that one way Trump can get a
plurality in a state but still win the
state
um I don't think that that is why
Republicans are joining you know I
actually don't remember whether in the
Republican primary it is winner take all
or not in every state I actually I I
don't remember that but regardless I
believe the main reason the main two
reasons that Republicans are joining the
Republican primary are number one
they want to be there if Trump totally
fails because of the indictments and
they just need to find someone else
that's number one they want to be there
and number two
they want to get attention including
potentially being considered to be
Donald Trump's own vice president I
believe that that's that's really the
point I don't believe that there have
been deals made to join in order to get
Trump or plurality or that that sort of
thing I've seen no evidence of that at
least
oh okay okay because there were some
people over here talking about that and
I'm like I didn't know about it but
people are very petrified of the idea of
another Trump understandably
understandably how are things in Paris
right now I'm going to be back there
soon in fact
oh things are fine now things are
perfectly fine it's actually jam-packed
with tourists really
it's jam-packed like if you go around
Walmart or like the I I could Triumph
it's absolutely full of tourists oh boy
I'm gonna have to avoid those areas I
guess Roberto
uh well if you're going in the summer
it's the worst time to come in the
mountain if you if you don't want to be
with tons of tourists right right the
summer is like the worst time
but there's plenty of places that are
quiet that don't get that many
absolutely
oh well Roberto thank you for the call I
appreciate it
thank you so much have a good day all
right Roberto from Paris France very
strong let's go to Ashley from Columbus
Ashley from Columbus welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
thank you for having me on today David
pleasure
was wondering what you thought of I
added an interesting take about the
target boycott from right Wingers okay
I first of all make it clear
what they did and what it goes that the
target gave in to the right Wingers and
I got some of that
LGBT stuff off of their shelves yep I
hate that
but I think it actually
helps show people on both sides of the
aisle that people can still have some
power over corporations sure the I think
the thing is we didn't we we did know
that but the only source of that power
is trying to impact
income and profitability at the end of
the day you know what I mean it's like
it's not I don't believe any of these
things we're seeing McDonald not
McDonald's M M's putting a pause on that
new thing they were doing with the
androgynous whatever all these different
things I think at the end of the day
it's just about the money
yeah but I it's it was about that but I
think with the recent news people I know
myself included have started doubting
our
hour to do this you saw what the rail
worker strikes the corporation can trust
the government to step in and save their
profits with this even if it's to a
horrible end yeah helps bring back that
belief that people can actually have
power over corporations and at least
gives me some hope that we can have some
change for good in the near future yeah
I don't totally disagree with you and
what I would like would there to be more
ways to have that power over
corporations that don't require major
government intervention that would be a
good thing
foreign
just glad to have a little bit of Hope
for something in our current political
climate absolutely Ashley from Columbus
thank you for the call
thank you for having me on all right
there goes Ashley why don't we go next
to
oh I don't know how about Patrick from
North Idaho Patrick from North Idaho
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
Patrick from North Idaho please accept
my invitation to join me
and last chance for Patrick from North
Idaho
well it's too bad it really is let's go
to Jack from Atlanta Jack from Atlanta
welcome to the program what can I do for
you today
hey David can you hear me yeah
awesome well thank you so much I have a
question I know you've repeatedly said
that you still do not believe that Trump
will ever see one day in prison I'm
still wondering given all the evidence
and the severity of this arraignment he
had yesterday and the charges being
right against them why do you still
believe that so I've actually updated my
view on this Jack and I'm glad to have
the opportunity to do it again prior to
this week prior to this recent
indictment I believe that there was no
chance Trump would even see a day inside
of any kind of cell I now believe that
it is unlikely but possible so I have
sort of upgraded or downgraded depending
on your perspective my uh my view on
that on the basis of this latest
indictment
well one could only hope and uh one last
quick question I I thought of it after
the last speaker uh gave his question do
you find it at all startling that a lot
of Corporations have actually foregone
posting their logo as a rainbow logo for
pride month because it used to be the
case where almost everyone would do that
but now I guess maybe they've realized
that hey now it's not financially viable
to do that anymore does that at all
scare you you know I don't know that to
be true and what I mean is I'm not
saying you're lying I just pay so little
attention to what corporations are doing
as far as the the logos I know that on
the very powerful David Pacman show
Discord we did do a modified server logo
that includes the rainbow stripe for the
month as we always do I I it's I'm not
are you aware like what specific
companies used to do it but aren't doing
it anymore
well I know I've seen like a lot of just
random companies like Cisco or Starbucks
will post their Twitter a profile
picture as their logo but the
rainbowified version and I feel like I
just have seen very few of those this
year and I mean I give and I just saw
this isn't exactly the logo thing but I
saw on the news today that Starbucks is
actually rolling back some of its Pride
decorations at over half of its stores
so I was just I don't know it's just a
little bit startling how now a lot of
Corporations I mean yeah rainbow
capitalism is a lot of times empty
virtue signaling but it's just I don't
know it's a little bit worrying that now
that's being it's it's being perceived
as hey this isn't the right thing to do
given the current political climate yeah
I mean because I don't have the actual
empirical information in front of me let
me comment in this way
we all know that the vast majority of
these decisions are simply marketing and
PR decisions to increase the bottom line
it wouldn't be shocking to me that if it
became disadvantageous to do the pride
thing that companies would immediately
stop doing it I would find it
disappointing and sad because that would
be a horrible thing that it's it's no
longer that it would be unprofitable in
some way to uh just say hey like we're
we're on board with with uh just
treating everybody the right way uh it
wouldn't be a huge shock because these
are at the end of the day they've always
been financially oriented decisions
exactly well thanks for taking my call
David have a good one my pleasure there
goes Jack from Atlanta very powerful
declarations there and we are glad to uh
glad to hear them why don't we go to
Mali from Utah Molly from Utah welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
hi
um so last time I got cut off I don't
know what happened but uh their thing I
was going to talk about is that the DSA
has over 185 seats both state local
including National okay Molly just just
just with total peace and love
if we can get I know that there was a
very long lead up going on and DSA is
not something that I'm super engaged
with and know very little about it so so
I just if we can get to the question
part relatively sooner even first I can
tell you whether I can even weigh in I
don't want to waste your time you know
yeah
um but it's basically that they've been
doing local actions they've been doing
local activities and have been gaining
ground so uh what do you think about
those efforts when it comes down to
electoral reform I know nothing about
what the DSA is doing or where they've
been gaining ground and as a
non-socialist myself it's not something
I'm advocating for
it's uh over the entire country they've
been getting on since 2016. and you you
mean in elected office yeah elected
offices both state and local and
National that there's like five members
of Congress that are DSA members listen
what I can tell you is when movements
succeed at getting candidates elected
it's good for them but beyond that it's
really tough for me to say say too much
more it's not a group I'm a member of or
when I'm you know supporting at this
time
okay I just I would recommend looking
they seem to be advancing pretty well
and that's just like the the Opium of
like change is possible they are able to
do it all right Molly from Utah thank
you very much for the call I appreciate
that let's take a very quick break we're
gonna go right back to Discord and hear
from more people so don't go anywhere
we're just taking a very short break
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's go
back to the phones they're not really
phones at this point It's All Digital we
take calls via Discord you can find the
Discord server at davidpackman.com slash
Discord let's go to Roy from Somalia Roy
from Somalia welcome to the program what
is on your mind today
Roy from Somalia please accept my
invitation and then we'll be able to
talk
my bad sir
um I was wondering about the situation
in Uganda with the um the gay rights
bill
um and how terrible it is and I was
wondering your thoughts on that yeah I
have this time around I mean this is the
same build that they've been following
for a very very long time if I recall
correct correctly I mean 10 years ago I
interviewed this crazy Pastor who was
supporting the bill
did we're talking about the same bill
right yeah that's right yeah listen
um it's so disgusting and in some sense
it's shocking that in 2023 this sort of
aggression against people simply for
being gay is still going on I am so far
removed from the specific comings and
goings of Ugandan politics that it's
really hard for me to say like what
needs to happen or what should happen I
mean there are people who follow that
specifically much more closely but it is
extremely disheartening that this is
even still that there's any effort being
wasted on scapegoating people and
targeting people for their identity it's
it's just disheartening and disgusting
at the at the end of the day
yeah I agree and only one member of of
their legislature actually voted against
it the others uh from the opposition
stayed home
um you know there's been U.S sanctions
and I think those should be ramped up
um but
it really is just unfortunate
unfortunate is the understatement of the
century Roy for sure do you live in
Somalia oh no that was a lie I'm from
South Jersey oh okay all right well very
very unusual uh on that note we're gonna
let you go uh try to tell the truth okay
guys try to tell the truth let's go next
to how about uh Dan from California Dan
from California welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
I do a lot of debates and discussions on
my YouTube channel I've done some with
Sam Cedar and I was wondering if you
would ever be up for a long form debate
I'm a big Iron Man Fan so uh that's the
perspective I'm coming from what would
the debate be about
maybe about politics or ethics I do
those topics a lot capitalism or egoism
yeah I mean maybe you know I'm really
limiting my appearances elsewhere just
because I'm so busy and to be totally
honest you might your channel might have
five million followers I don't know and
this is not how I base my decisions but
very often there's like very little
upside and it just it dominates my
schedule you know I want to have as
clear as schedule as possible so like
maybe the way to request that would be
to email in
okay it might make a difference if I
offered to pay uh no it really wouldn't
okay yeah I mean like how much would it
be worth to you I don't know maybe it
should
I don't know man like a hundred bucks
for that give me no no I'm kidding I'm
kidding around no it would not make a
difference unless the amount was way
higher Dan please
okay no I'm kidding around I I might do
it but I'm really I'm really Limited in
what I'm doing just because I'm so busy
what is what would be your biggest gripe
with my perspective I guess is my first
question
well I guess one fundamental issue which
probably underlies political issues is
your ethics so I don't know what your
view in ethics is but do you think
people have a moral rights to live for
their own sake
that would be one key question or should
they be forced to sacrifice for other
people yeah see this is this is another
reason why I tend not to do these sorts
of debates I exist in a place where I
find many of those questions do people
have a right to live for themselves or
should they be forced to sacrifice for
others well the the first question is
what kinds of societies do we even
believe are best or or advisable and one
of the unfortunate not maybe unfortunate
but like when I hear that question Dan
and this is why these often end up being
philosophical black holes one of the
biggest things when I hear that question
is
if we start from the point that we have
societies of more than 150 people quite
frankly and more than a thousand right
the US has 330 million people
it almost seems not super relevant
whether I think that in some theoretical
context we have a quote right to live
for ourselves or should be quote forced
to live for others if we want to be in
this type of society we are going to
centralize some aspects of society and
the economy while hopefully finding a
balance that still allows people
reasonable amounts of self-determination
if that if for me I start there because
this is the society I live in and if I
don't like that I would then look at
okay maybe I need to find a different
Society where the dichotomy you raise is
actually feasible it's less interesting
to just abstractly discuss the dichotomy
you bring up I don't think we get much
out of it if that's fair
I think taxes you know that exists in
our society so we all have to deal with
that if that's a case where I would say
we're forced to sacrifice what we would
choose to do with our own money for the
sake of other people so I think it is
very relevant to you I mean on taxes
you're not forced to work right like you
could choose not to work
yeah but if you do choose to work you're
forced to give away some of your
earnings to other people but you said
you said if you choose to what you did
say if you choose to work right choose
is different than Force you acknowledge
that
yes okay and if you don't like the tax
structure of the United States you could
look to go to a different place I
understand it's difficult to stop paying
taxes to the United States but there are
different conventions you could renounce
your citizenship et cetera like you
agree that you could also kind of take
your take your toys and leave to some
degree
as a right to put you in that kind of
position the government's rights tax I
don't think it has a right to tax it
only has rights that are delegated to it
as Citizens but the citizens themselves
don't have a right to coerce others so
they can't delegate the right to
co-course others to the government okay
so basically it's like you're kind of
like a standard utopian libertarian it
sounds like
I'm not a YouTube utilitarian I'm an
objectivist Utopia utopian
all right well it's all very interesting
Dan listen if people hear this and think
it would be interesting for me to do
three hours on this let me know and then
I'll do Dan's show and Dan you can email
in and give me more info okay
all right thanks David appreciate it
there goes Dan and iron Rand fan and
listen we'll look into it it's just not
usually like the best use of anybody's
time that's been that's been my
experience which is why I kind of tend
to tend not to do it let's go to Isaiah
from Florida Isaiah from Florida Welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
oh hello I just actually had a bunch of
topics but I think I want to stick with
Florida my main question is how do you
think Democrats could potentially like
be competitive in the state again like
like they were under like the Obama
coalition
I think losing by 20 points to
you know with DeSantis and Chris I think
that some Democrats fear that or think
maybe we should just leave Florida alone
I just don't think that I want to know
your thoughts no no listen I don't think
the situation in Florida is nearly as
bad as some people are making it out to
be Florida has tons of Democrats and
left-leading independents the issue in
Florida is DeSantis had a very strong
bully pulpit you know incumbency
advantage and he was lucky in a sense
that the 2022 midterms
took place right at sort of like the
peak of anti-woke and since November
like in the last eight months we've
started to see anti-woke fade a little
bit we've started to see polling that
shows the tide is turning DeSantis has
humiliated himself in a bunch of
different ways I don't know that he has
any path to the to the Republican
nomination so I actually think first of
all on the 19 Point Victory that
DeSantis had de sanctimonious I think
that uh it would be it would be far
smaller if it if that election were held
today number two
part of the issue in Florida and this is
relevant in the whole country is that
voter turnout is so low that if
Democrats can just work to increase
voter turnout the way Biden increased
voter turnout in 2020 on the basis of
like hey you realize if you stay home
Trump might get another four years
um you can you can win in Florida just
by working on voter turnout and so I
think it would be a major mistake a
summer talking about to like abandon
Florida what I will say though Isaiah is
Trump won Florida in 2020 and he still
lost the Electoral College by a lot so
it's important for us to know nationally
we don't need Florida for Joe Biden to
win re-election but within the state I
would not give up on Florida at all at
all
yeah see my view is I think what they
should do is focus more on the local
level first and then try to go Statewide
and I'm with you because Trump Biden's
loss in Florida was not that was not as
much as what Chris was to the santis
right and I actually think part of it
was because a lot of Democrats here they
just were not thrilled for Charlie Chris
I really think that's what the main
issue was and because you know covet
that that issue kind of helped him
because of the message he was able to to
relay on covid but yeah I agree with you
on the anti on the anti-walk stuff yep
all right let's keep fighting in Florida
critically uh
um a significant State at the state and
uh local level would like to have it
nationally but you don't need it
yeah well that's all I have thank you
for taking my call and I love supporting
your show all right there goes Isaiah
from Florida with some very very
important things just as a reminder to
people who are waiting to be on name and
location or location and name should be
in your nickname uh if it's just like
just just a nickname or that sort of
thing you're not going to get called on
just so people know let's go to Omar
from Atlanta Omar from Atlanta welcome
to the program what is on your mind
today
hello can you hear me yes I can
yeah so I think the other Atlanta
gentleman had a similar question it's
kind of about the Trump uh indictment
recently on these documents so my
question is is that especially since the
ESPN object has been used to prosecute
people at least the left would assume to
be heroes like reality winner and
whatnot first of all what are your
thoughts on the hypocrisy of reality
winner from the moment of arrest to uh
being released never saw a foot outside
of jail and hypocrisy there with Trump
and secondly on whether or not we should
be cheering on the Espionage Act to be
used against Trump like this
I don't have any
philosophical opposition
to it being used I can it is not unique
that statutes and law
can be used in ways we don't agree with
that is that's not that's not a unique
thing and that alone doesn't make me say
this is suspect this is bad or whatever
the case may be we are we just got the
indictment we are eventually going to
see what this case is built on and we're
all going to be able to sort of Judge
for ourselves whether the Espionage is
correct or incorrect now I think it's
important to say Trump is not accused of
spying for another country a lot of
people are hearing the word Espionage or
Espionage Act and assuming certain
things that are not actually part of the
indictment let's not allow the word I
mean the Espionage Act contains a number
of different Provisions if the
indictment is accurate Trump did violate
the Espionage Act doesn't mean spied for
Russia so I think it's way too certainly
too early to say it's incorrect to
charge them in that way
right yeah he uh he's charged with
improperly holding documents not sharing
them yeah I guess from my perspective
it's because we have that Georgia case
building up right now I would have much
preferred to see that in the Limelight
than Espionage Act violations which just
seems at least personally less tenuous
from a political perspective there's
also a number of different charges and
it's obstruction and it's a whole bunch
of different things and it's also a
false notion to say the only thing Trump
did wrong was having the documents it
actually goes much further than that and
in fact this is the point why you have
to look at what Hillary was was
investigated for to understand it's not
about holding documents
and refusing to return them yeah
absolutely yeah that's fair
all right Omar from Atlanta thank you
for the call thank you all right very uh
very direct question I like that why
don't we go next to Zach from New York
Zach welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hi David thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
so uh my question for you is which
political figure
do you think has the biggest
differential between how serious they
appear versus how big of a clown they
actually are
let me think about this the big and it
could be it could be that they are more
or less serious than their than their
public perception right it could be
either way
I I guess so but I'm more interested in
who appears to be very serious but is
actually a very big clown ah you know
Mitch McConnell comes to mind
both his seniority and his confidence in
answering even about things he has no
clue on make him seem extremely serious
to many people
and I think that at the end of the day
he actually is a total clown so so
McConnell comes to mind I'm trying to
think who else you know the thing about
Trump is he's not serious and he doesn't
seem serious so it's like it's very
obviously not Trump you know
you can spot that clown a mile away you
know maybe Pence would be in the running
because especially next to Trump Pence
seemed so sober and serious but his
beliefs are just built on crumbling
trash you know just a dumpster fire uh
so I would put pence in the running as
well
okay I like that answer
thank you all right well thank you Zach
I appreciate it Zach from New York that
is it is actually a tough question when
you don't think about it uh super super
uh specifically all right everybody
let's take a break we will take more
calls again if I have anything to say
about it
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get to Friday feedback
Friday I like to take a look at what
folks have been saying you know it we
get five or six thousand different
comments a day across email YouTube Tick
Tock Etc it's impossible to look at all
of them but I like to take a look at a
sampling and see some of the criticisms
that people are making some of the
praise and some of the questions that
people are asking so let's start first
and foremost let's just get this out of
the way okay
392 Choppa on YouTube says who is paying
you
this is a question rarely asked in good
faith it usually implies that some
nefarious forces are funding this
program or that I only am saying the
things I'm saying because someone is
giving me money or whatever the case may
be so let me clarify we fund this
program
through three General categories number
one memberships people who just sign up
on the website so like 392 Chapa could
just as easily be one of the people
paying me as anybody else that's one of
our funding sources secondly
the plat some of the platforms we're on
provide ad revenue for the little ads
that show up like before a video or in
between videos and that includes
um YouTube that includes Facebook that
includes more recently Tick Tock uh not
Instagram okay so that's another funding
source and then lastly direct ad sales
that we do so like when you hear me
talking about a product or service the
that's who pays me there's no big
millionaire billionaire donor there's no
DNC money I'm not even a Democrat I
don't know why the DNC would pay me if I
tell you things that I like about
Democrats and things I don't not clear
what why there would be an incentive
there
um and that's basically the bottom line
that's it there's nothing sketchy or
secret going on uh and one of the great
things about that way of being funded is
there is no one person that can even
attempt to hold money over our heads to
get me to say or not say whatever
there's no single Advertiser that's so
big that they could come and say hey we
really don't like what you're saying
about X or Y or whatever they would say
listen we we have many advertisers and
we aside from the fact that I would
never do that even financially like you
you don't really have me over a barrel
same thing with our audience members one
person who's a member says David I will
pull my three dollars a month
if you don't take back that thing you
said it's there's just no leverage okay
there's no leverage so that's who is
paying me and by the way organizations
like the daily wire and others actually
do have the big donors organizations
like Turning Point USA have the big
donors focus on them there's no exciting
story about who's paying us so Scotty
Roden and Scotty says I know you won't
but I feel a ton of us want you to run
for president well Scotty I legally
cannot run for president of the United
States I was not born
in the United States I was born in
Argentina and at least for now maybe
Arnold Schwarzenegger will get the law
changed at some point I'm not sure I
would not legally be allowed to run for
president so I hate to if if it is true
that there are a ton of us that want me
to run for president as Scotty says I
hate to disappoint but it's just not
going to be possible under current law
John tool says I wouldn't vote for Chris
Christie but it is nice to hear a
republican sound more like they used to
again it's just nice to see a republican
talking on an adult level again as of
now Christy really does have the
strongest campaign start on the
Republican side hands down agree
completely it's not even close it's not
even close Vivek ramaswami's campaign is
just a mess it's like a verbal verbal
ink plot uh Nikki Haley's campaign is a
joke Tim Scott's campaign is laughable
Mike Pence's couldn't possibly have less
energy okay you go through all of them
then you get to Ron DeSantis he's just a
complete and total disaster in terms of
his campaign focus on anti-woke his
inability to in any remotely charismatic
way actually go against the guy who's
leading which is Trump then we get Trump
okay you got Trump it's Christy it's CR
and I am not voting for Christy I'm not
a republican I'm it's just if I had to
vote for a republican it's so obviously
Chris Christie and John is finding uh
that he's coming away with the same
perspective
Bruton rode on Reddit
says there's a growing number of people
in my community and others believing
conservative propaganda that Democrats
are the party of slavery and it's
working why aren't we trying to stop
this yes I know Democrats in the 1800s
did form the Confederacy but we also
know pushing the narrative in 2023 that
Democrats are the true racist party
without full and proper context is
clearly agenda based and not a good
faith discussion my question is why
isn't more being done to combat this I'm
guessing most people don't not seeing
how big of a problem this is becoming in
the black community well listen a couple
things first of all I don't know that
it's becoming a big problem in the black
community because if black folks were
being tricked into thinking that the
modern democratic party is the party of
slavery you wouldn't see such high
levels of support for Democratic
candidates from the black community
black folks and Jewish folks are the two
groups that most vote Democratic in the
United States States and my belief is
that if either of those groups were
falling for the lie that the Democrats
of the Confederacy or the Democrats of
2023 you wouldn't see those levels of
support that being said yes I do think
it would be better to more strongly
disabuse people of the notion that there
is a connection between Democrats of the
Civil War era and Democrats of 2023 in
order to explain this you do have to go
into some history about party
realignments and different things I I
think that it's worth doing part of it
would be great to do
in school at the educational level and
prevent people from Ever falling for
this stuff in the first place but the
one part I take issue with this viewer
is that I'm not seeing the evidence that
it is really convincing too many people
um doesn't mean we don't want to combat
it but it doesn't seem like as big an
issue as this person is worried about
Chris Ortiz comments why don't what what
you don't get Bud is the reason the
economy is so strong is because of what
Trump did in his first term and I guess
you forget how high inflation really is
I love guys like you you point at every
bad point of a person but offer no new
insight I bet you call yourself an
independent typical but I may be wrong
well listen I am not a democrat or a
republican in that sense I'm independent
but I don't pretend to be a Centrist or
anything like that I'm on the left but
when it comes to economic matters I try
to remove Politics as much as possible
and just give you the analysis based on
the data the empirical analysis there is
no evidence I can find that the current
economic indicators are what they are
because of what Donald Trump did in his
first term however Chris I also so don't
go around putting the credit for the
economy being what it is squarely on the
shoulders of Joe Biden presidents in
general make tweaks that can affect the
general direction of the economy but
much of what is going on is bigger than
the United States and it's certainly
bigger than what's in the Oval Office
the point I make about the Biden economy
is that there is a group that says Biden
doesn't deserve a second term
because the economy is so terrible and
there is no empirical database case that
you can make that proves the economy is
terrible that's my point Vinnie wrote in
and says I find it crazy that DeSantis
is now running on quote destroying the
left and the media acts like this is
normal politics and not fascism imagine
if a Democrat ran on getting rid of all
conservatism that would be on 24 7 loop
on Fox and any other right-wing Outlet
this guy is full on anti-democracy and
nobody seems to care 100 listen that
applies to so many stories imagine if
Barack Obama was indicted on 37 counts
and it turned out that he obstructed an
attempt to return classified documents
uh to their uh rightful
custodians that a server room was
flooded by draining the pool at his
Resort that he had boxes of classified
documents stacked up around his toilet
just imagine how this the coverage would
be different from the right and
similarly Rhonda Santa said if I I will
destroy the leftism if I become
president
if Joe Biden said we will destroy
conservatism
they would be saying this guy is an
authoritarian fascist he's dangerous uh
all of the things that we know they try
to say at any opportunity Vinnie is
completely right there is a stunning
double standard out there about this
issue Dennis says about Ron DeSantis he
is stopping homosexuality in school
not Banning educational books I don't
know if Dennis actually means this but
you realize that if what Ron DeSantis is
trying to do is to stop homosexuality in
schools that that's extraordinarily
disturbing what does it mean to stop
homosexuality because Dennis isn't
saying stopping discussion of
homosexuality in school
Dennis seems to be saying stopping
homosexuality in school you're going to
ban gay people from what going to school
teaching what are you talking about
Dennis this is someone who's trying to
defend DeSantis and actually makes it
look even worse
lastly on the trans and drag issue
Richard Martin said if you want to raise
your kid to be a freak Show moved to
another country don't put that stuff in
the school system and try to screw up
other kids heads if you want your kid to
be a freak show that you're a business
to take him down to a gay bar throwing
in the door let them have them and leave
a note on his back saying this week drop
off when you're done with them have fun
simple solves the problem that is one
sentence no punctuation and it is not
even worthy of a response other than to
remind you
this and this person also has a Jack
Daniels bottle as their profile picture
this is what we are up against
and as I've said before
we're not going to convince Richard
Martin that he's wrong in any reasonable
amount of time
and so what we have to do instead is
activate people who don't plan to vote
that's the much more direct and
efficient path towards trying to win
elections really sad stuff going on in
this country we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today just a reminder that
we will be off on Monday the federal
holiday Juneteenth I hope everybody has
a great Monday whether you're working or
not we will be off and then uh we'll be
back the rest of the week all right
everybody great bonus show today sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indict it again indict it again
thank you